oh this one last question I remember and
it was about the 25th anniversary of
25th birthday of c60 and it's an
interesting one because in fact in 1982
1984 I was visiting Bob Carrol at Rice
University
and he suggested I go and see Rick
Smalley who had done some brilliant work
in developing cluster beam technique a
method for detecting clusters of
refractory materials materials that
didn't weren't volatile and so I went
over and whilst Rick was telling me how
things what he was doing is a boolean
character and I thought well maybe it
can explain these carbon chain molecules
that we detected some years beforehand
and that was 1984 now a few months later
in June June July a paper came out from
the Exxon lab that had done the
experiment that I suggested and they had
detected a carbon clusters way above 30
I mean I actually knew some early work
by Hinton burger that had seen clusters
of carbon up to 33 or so and I
conjectured that these were linear
chains and which they and probably most
of them were maybe one the cyclic rings
and anyway to cut a long story short
around July 1984 my colleague Tony Stace
gave me this interesting paper from the
Exxon lab where they'd seen clusters up
to 100 and 120 look to this wow this is
interesting and in fact these were
numbered and 40 50 60 60 was with
stronger than others and simply in fact
there was a signal of C 60 they're a
little bit later
another group at Bell Labs so looks at
the same system and picked off C 60 and
and they fought to fragmented it because
it was you know stronger than other
things and not but they didn't seem to
have asked the question of what it might
be so then not only that after we okay
well let's go on because I've come back
to this point about a year and a half
later I got a phone call from Bob Carol
was i interested in coming to Rice
University to do this experiment because
I suggested this experiment Tabar
brilliant he'd written to me letters me
a letter story and fro about the
complexity of the second part of the
problem but anyway so we're going to at
least do us together starts on it and so
I I said you know are you coming or
should we send you the data no there's a
little thing lesson you go and do your
own experiment because if something
special exciting turns up and it's not
what you predicted you won't be involved
you'll never be involved in the bit that
you predicted in any way to custard on
so try when and of course we discovered
C 60 now during this experiments the we
saw these signals but on the fourth of
September I wrote on my printout C 60
question mark C 60 huge and c 70 as well
and one of the students you Anna also
wrote on the 4th of September the same
thing that c 60 is very strong indeed
and so although C 60 had been seen
before I think it was the fourth of
September on which we realized that it
was a little bit special and this is
something exceptional and in fact you
could say that its birthday or its
conception was in 1970 when AG also were
had the brilliant idea that perhaps the
60 molecule could form be stable and he
published that in Japanese
and also in a book later with his
professor Yoshida and so you could say
the the year of conception was 1970 and
it took five years to to be born also as
a paper by David Jones who wrote on the
pseudonym of died Alice who predicted
that a graphite sheet would curve into a
ball if you had 12 Pentagon's so he I
think takes the credit for the first
carbon cage although I think there was a
paper who or someone who suggested that
see 6860 my form was about the same time
but I think those are the main ones are
pure carbon and so about a year and a
half ago I met a lady from Google lorry
park and I sort of mentioned well you
have these nice google anniversaries
where you commemorate things and how
about commemorating the birthday of c60
on the 4th of September 1985 but with
the 25th anniversary in 2010 and she
said well she passed it on and the
people at Google came back to me a few
months ago I said well we're interested
in this and they put together a special
google doodle on the 4th of September
and I think it was very nice because it
was interactive and they told me that
they sold quite a few had to solve quite
a few problems to make it come down very
quickly and perhaps more people learned
about c60 in one day of Google than in
25 years of research and papers and
magazine articles about it
interesting on my colleague andreas
motion is looking into it he he thought
it might well be the biggest publicity
exercise that c60 had ever had so it was
great that there was a Google doodle and
I'm sure lots of kids around the world
enjoyed a little bit of playing
interactive playing with the doodle and
probably learned some thing about not
only c60 is a soccer ball but also maybe
learn something about the chemistry and
buckminster fuller's domes and had a
little bit of fun as well it was great